so that's where we've come from so far I
want to use one of these as our launch
pad into the next little bit which is
actually going to be the last set of
planned checks are going to look like
it's the last set of shapes we need to
go and do this outdoor female airplane
okay so I want you to have a look at
these shapes us don't call out the
answer just yet I want you to think
about the question I posed to you okay
so what you look at these shapes I want
you to suppose that I tell you I've got
a shape in my head and the shape that
I've got in mind has two pairs of equal
signs I said you guys are the worst
okay so I want to ask you okay ask nice
firstly this time I'm not gonna ask
nicely shut up and wait get the kid
gloves come on okay so let me pedal back
a little bit right I've got a shape in
mind you might want to drop this down I
have two pairs of equal sides
okay two pairs of equal sides right sure
then the question comes what shape is in
my mind now it could be actually more
than one shape right so some answer to
get caught out might be right but this
is all I'm thinking of not know more
details than that okay
any takers yep okay it could be a
rectangle let's think about this how
does it work two pairs of equal sides
which sides are they oh right but the
top and bottom they're equal and then
the left and right sides re tick okay
triangle we might have a bit of trouble
because it doesn't have two pairs of
sides so I'm gonna be stuck there okay
yeah
the one day the tribal who remembers
what school a strong power that Legrand
thank you very much okay so let's have a
look at option two option two
yeah also and in exactly the same way as
the rectangle right look
stop it bought it and then these sides
here okay now I'm not just content
enough to give you a diagram I'll show
you right because I'm these diagrams
here they're kind of static yeah sir
you'll have to wait let's get two pairs
of equal sides right now
haven't quite tested this so hopefully
it'll work out the one this isn't too
heavy okay I have a two pairs of equal
sides here okay and the point is that I
can you can put them however you like
aware of you like okay so if I put
another one down yeah okay so I took
cares of equal sides right now I have
another pair of equal sides but you'll
notice I've colored them and you can
probably see a bit they are not the same
length right so they're not equal to the
original pair but they're equal to each
other you can take with that I thought
I'll try and put this one on nice and
firmly put that one I contemplated doing
this on the floor because I was like
that's gonna be hard to see her I'll put
this one over here okay we'll try it
we'll try this one again a little bit is
that going to work roughly well actually
if the if the people the good people in
the woodwork shop can be trusted it
should be the scale and I think so this
will have to do happy looks all right
doesn't it okay so this is really cool
because you can see look you've got this
shape well lead it the other way okay
but you can see how I could go from this
shape to this shape what would I do to
it how could I adjust it anyone want to
would you cool okay so let's do this
right this reason why I got all this
cutout right uh if I I think what we
were saying was wondering a right angle
okay so I'm gonna take this troublesome
piece off again okay and if I just take
these two sides it's still equal yeah
and I just rotating down how's that does
that look right angle to you so all I've
done is I adjusted it a little bit right
if we put back this guy again I have to
be careful with okay have a look at what
we've got okay question is this shape a
parallelogram
okay so let's consider what makes a
parallelogram a parallelogram it's even
in the name it means you've got parallel
sides right at least two sides parallel
yeah yeah are these two parallel oh yes
they are
this is a parallelogram it's a special
power if you just put one right angle or
one right angle in a parallel you'll get
a rectangle okay so far so good
yes sir
you'll come back to this it'll be off at
an angle okay yep all right so so far so
good but come back to this right two
pairs of equal sides so we've said on
the fact that basically we're looking at
a parallelogram and it might be a
rectangle but the whole point is that
rectangles are just special
parallelograms okay here's another
option there's another option this is
what happens when you're two pairs of
equal sides are where are they in
relation to each other
well this one is opposite to this one
right top and bottom these two opposite
left and right I'll just I'll just wait
till everyone's
top and bottom nothing right so that's
opposite right opposite but where else
where else could I arrange these two
pairs of equal sides they might not be
opposite they might be I'll write it
down they might be adjacent okay so what
would this look like get your pen out
before I get to it what would it look
like if again you have the same two
pairs of equal sides but you didn't make
them opposite to each other you place
them beside each other you draw it go
ahead
draw it and see what you get if you've
got two pairs of equal sides and you
place them opposite to each other then
you get if you play some opposite to
each other and if you place them
adjacent to each other then lo and
behold you get a kite okay now the
reason why I put my sideways is because
I know that what I want to do next won't
fix long ways okay you remember I said
two pairs of equal signs okay well we've
got one more shape to look after the
kite which is what happens if you make
the two pairs right if you make them
rather than two pairs that are different
what if you make two pairs but are the
same so if we ditch these two right the
pairs that are different and if we
replace them with another pair that
signal but equal to the original right
okay you can have a look you don't get a
choice right no matter how you place the
sides if you're going to use these
lengths and have them all equal to each
other then lo and behold what you get is
well you might call it a diamond but the
proper name is a rhombus okay so your
two pairs of equal science depending
which way you go you get one of these or
one of these right if you take your
client where they're adjacent or you
take your parallelogram where they're
opposite no matter which way you go okay
if you make both pairs
cool you'll get a okay there you go
I've just kiddin